guy who ultimately replaced alex smith
in kansas city patrick mahomes drafted
four years ago
this month with the clear understanding
that after one more season with alex
smith then mahomes would become the
starting quarterback here he is meeting
with reporters today at the opening of
the chief's offseason program talking
about the surgery to repair the turf toe
that he had in his big left toe here's
my homes
i mean i think i'm progressing well
i think i'm ahead of schedule myself i
mean obviously we're trying to be
cautious and not push me out there too
soon um but i'm doing what i can i've
gotten out of the boot finally it took
forever
and now i'm getting trying to get back
on the field and get that stuff working
and so uh
i'm sure they'll keep me along that same
pathway that i can be able to hopefully
do some stuff by the end of the off
season
yeah bye bye to the boot we saw the
picture on easter sunday with his family
the boot raised a lot of eyebrows by
thursday of that week out of the boot
when he was in the product placement
shots at augusta for his deal with
adidas so it wasn't entirely clear
whether the boot was permanently gone or
it was just shed long enough to to take
the pictures in whatever the new
offering is from adidas that they want
people to buy hey they got two free
mentions here by virtue of that but look
no reason to think he won't be ready to
go the bigger question is can he avoid
it in the future because will he have to
run around
all year long like he had to run around
all year long this year to the point
where eventually a ligament in your big
toe in either foot is going to get
strained and going to get torn and going
to need to be surgically repaired
well yeah and i think that that's
something that the chiefs clearly have
to solve they've been working to try and
solve it on their offensive line trying
to get guys who can help protect patrick
holmes they obviously they went after
trent williams that didn't quite work
out for their left tackle situation but
they were able to bring in joe thune
that i think is an upgrade at guard you
know they also brought in kyle long from
retirement that should maybe be an
upgrade at guard depending on how good
he is in shape and all that but they
still have to figure out who their left
tackle is going to be and it's not just
who their left tackle is going to be to
start they got to figure out who their
backup left tackle is going to be too
because look that's why patrick mahomes
had to run around for nearly 500 yards
behind the line of scrimmage in the
super bowl is because their backup left
tackle and really it was i think the
third left tackle at that point or
whatever the combination of offensive
line they had to do it just wasn't good
enough at that point so whenever you
have something like that depth is
extremely important and it's why some
teams have been able to withstand
injuries and be successful as they go
along patrick mahomes is one of the
greatest people to ever throw a football
like i mean look at what he does it's
incredible every single throw sometimes
you just kind of drop your jaw but at
the same time if you can't protect him
that's going to be a problem so the
chiefs definitely still need to solve
that offensive line issue
yeah they gotta have a page or two in
the playbook too where they keep a tight
end in the block keeper running back in
to knock down a defensive lineman who
gets around the edge and is coming after
patrick mahomes because especially with
an injured toe he can't run circles
around guys the way that he did
without the injured toe one way to keep
him healthy improve the offensive line
here's an exchange from the media
availability today regarding the
offensive line he was asked about it he
gave an answer here it is
yeah i mean i think we have a lot of
great guys in that offensive line room
uh guys that are ready to compete guys
uh that played last year and guys that
have a lot of experience coming in um
and that that breeds competition and you
love that that's in every single room in
this in this locker room is competition
you're gonna go out there compete and
try to earn your way to earning a spot
and uh to find a way to be the best
player you can be to try to get us to
the super bowl based on the story last
year of andy and brad reaching out to
you during the first round of the draft
do you feel like you'll have a bit of a
say uh come this year with regards to
how to you know keep fortifying that
offensive line
yeah i mean i try to i try to give my
input on on everything i can in this
building of trying to help out the team
in the best way possible
by the end of the day i trust and veach
and i trust in coach reed to make the
right decision for the the betterment of
the team um and so if they ask me i'll
give my input and do all that do that
different type of stuff but they have a
pretty good track
track record of getting great players in
this building
yeah yeah they do they do they drafted
him yes yes
that would have been great that would
have been an ultimate moment if he would
have said you know by virtue of the fact
that i'm standing here talking to you
they know what they're doing and they
know how to do it but they definitely
miles need to focus some of that on
the offensive line and depth along the
offensive line and they did try to get
trent williams didn't work and you know
we thought super team we thought between
the bucks and the chiefs super team
there were a couple of guys they wanted
to get that they didn't get and they'd
love to have had trent williams but
there's options in the draft and they're
going to need to get guys in and coach
him up and get him ready to go with my
homes you don't have to be anthony munoz
in his prime because he will buy plenty
of time on his own but it would be nice
if he didn't have to
given what happened last year with that
foot
nice anthony munoz dropped there uh mike
yeah he probably doesn't have to be
anthony munoz in his prime i don't
really remember any anthony munoz's
career but you know that's okay uh i
think that what they're doing though
with the offensive line is going to be
interesting because they pick at 31st
right and there is some good depth
apparently with this offensive tackle
and offensive line class so they're
going to have options now who exactly
those options are going to be remains to
be seen especially when you're picking
that low in the first round but i think
we saw last year that they made the most
of that low first round pick by getting
a guy like clyde edward solaire and when
you're picking that low and you have a
team that has been to the super bowl for
the last two years you understand that
there are only certain needs that you
have and we always talk about picking
the best player available and all that
but i think it's more important to pick
a guy who fits what you do and you know
that especially when you're getting that
guy in the first round you can plug them
in and they can play and you're gonna
have that guy for five years at least in
theory because of that fifth year option
so
because of all of that i think that
they're going to be able to pick
somebody who's going to be able to come
in there and help them whether it's at
the offensive line or otherwise we'll
have to see but at least looking at it
right now you have to think they're
thinking offensive line
yeah absolutely and we know from four
years ago they're not bashful about
trading up to get a guy they love they
went 27 to 10 to get pat from homes in
the 2017 draft and like many other teams
the fact that there will be a run on
quarterbacks out of the gates could be
as many
as six taken before the chiefs pick at
number 31
that means more players that fit their
needs get pushed down the board and the
chiefs are in that zone where they could
trade out
of that spot get some extra picks and
instead of rolling the dice on the best
available offensive lineman at 31
get an extra lottery ticket get more
depth get two bodies for the price of
one by giving that 31st pick to somebody
who maybe wants to come up to take what
would be the sixth quarterback in the
draft one more cut from mahomes and this
relates to
the motivation that he has acquired not
through winning but through losing
specifically the super bowl 31-9 to the
tampa bay buccaneers here's my homes
the first year that i started we lost to
the patriots in the afc championship
game i mean you have to let that stuff
motivate you to get better each and
every day and so um
you look back at that and we were able
to find a way to kind of flip a switch
and make ourselves better and make a run
at super bowl the next year and you have
to try to have that same mentality of
knowing that we've been there two years
in a row now we've won one we lost one
we have to find a way to get back and
try to win it
yeah look you find motivation in your
success you might you find maybe even
more in your failure and you think about
the run of greatness this team has had
three straight afc championships two
straight super bowls and i think it is
that
that shattering that comes from losing
at the highest level
that allows you to go back to zero and
zero and start building again with a
goal in mind it's always hard to say we
just climbed the mountain what are we
gonna do this year we're gonna climb the
mountain you mean the mountain we just
climbed yeah you're gonna go climb it
again when you've been thrown back to
the bottom that gives you a little more
of a kick and they are to be more driven
this year and mahomes learning from that
tormented by that gets into the whole
trevor lawrence discussion sims and i
had today but tormented by adversity to
the point where it drives you to try to
achieve more greatness and it sounds
like that's what's going to happen for
my homes well the great ones and you
this is probably something you discuss
with sims because you wrote it too the
great ones seem to have that screw loose
and they seem to find motivation in even
the slightest of slights right and this
one is not really slight of a slight you
know it's a pretty big thing that
happened they went to the super bowl
they tried to run it back they almost
did but they came up short and they lost
in a way that i don't think anybody
anticipated that they would have lost
right 31-9 is certainly not a score that
i was thinking that we would see from
the buccaneers and also the chiefs so
from that standpoint yeah i think
patrick mahomes is certainly very
motivated to get back to that level and
he said that you know he's watched the
super bowl a couple of times it still
stings tyron matthew kind of said the
same sort of thing he's watched it five
six times you know since that super bowl
that game and that it hurts every single
time but what matthew said i thought was
interesting and it's that you know this
is the kind of loss that can sometimes
derail a team and so they have to use it
as fuel but they also have to put it
behind them in order to make sure that
they can get back to that level because
every team every year is different so
you can certainly use that loss as
motivation but you also have to realize
like yeah we're still starting at zero
and we've got to climb that mountain
again and you know we've seen it happen
in recent years right the patriots one
in 2016 the super bowl then they lost in
2017 and then they beat the rams in the
super bowl nobody remembers in 2018 so
we've seen this happen in recent years
and it'll be interesting to see how the
chiefs do it
just because you would like to forget it
doesn't mean that
no one else remembers it mike nobody
remembers that super bowl they were
playing super bowls on nfl network a few
weeks ago and they went from the 2016
super bowl to the 2017 super bowl to the
super bowl that the chiefs won nobody
remembers that super bowl
i thought it was great i loved being
there maroon 5 played at halftime i love
maroon 5 something that most people
don't actually say or admit to but i do
so i thought it was great but nobody
remembers that super bowl man
the thing about patrick mahomes
because
when we were talking about this i'm
thinking here's a guy
who is never going to be
borderline petty
about
disses and slights but you know i
remembered when they played the bears a
couple of years ago and things were
going well
one two three four you know and he
counts ten
oh ten
against the guy that they drafted before
him eight spots and then
last year against the ravens he goes one
two three four five
or four whatever it was oh it was four
because it was the number of touchdown
passes he threw i believe but it was
also he was the fourth best player in
the nfl according to that that time
filler poll that the nfl does every year
and lamar jackson was number one
so
he's not above
finding motivation
in the dumbest and most superficial and
meaningless of places if it gives him
that little kick in the butt the thing
is
when he shows it it's in moments like
that and there's something kind of
charming about it he's not going to get
behind a podium and whine about it he's
going to go do something about it and
then you're going to see a cheeky little
reaction by him as he's making his way
to the sideline after he throws another
touchdown pass
yes i'm glad you brought that up because
that's the one thing that i was thinking
about him counting on his fingers
especially that game against the bears
and then of course he did it like you
said against lamar jackson look this is
a guy who has that gene where he just
takes whatever slight he can and he uses
it as motivation and that is what the
greatest ones do and the other funny
thing about him is you're saying he's
not going to stand behind that podium
and then start talking about exactly
what he was doing he even denied the
fact that what he was doing with that
mitchell trubisky thing with when he was
picked 10th overall and trubisky was
picked second he he denied that that had
anything to do with drafting she's like
i don't know i was just counting things
on my fingers yes sir you are the count
because that's all you wanted right no
we know what you were doing he knows
what he was doing but he's not so petty
that he's going to tell you exactly what
he was doing maybe in 20 years or
whatever it is we'll get a documentary
like we got from michael jordan and
he'll say all the things that you know
who confirm all the things that we
actually know about him now
and to spin it back to trevor lawrence
the reality is he's yet to have anything
that could be regarded as a slight
unless he wants to say i should have won
a heisman trophy and i'm upset about
that but he's going to be the first
overall pick we've known he was going to
be the first overall pick in this draft
since his true freshman season so no one
is doubting him the only thing he can
have a chip on his shoulder about is
whether or not he's got a chip on his
shoulder so maybe he's starting to learn
because he kind of did have a chip on
his shoulder over the weekend about the
fact that people were criticizing him
for not having a chip on his shoulder
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports